our subject for this afternoon
promise and power
for those of you who didn't hear what i
said
i'm very grateful to god very seriously
grateful for this privilege i really
mean that from my heart
i thank him for it the honor of
preaching is an honor angels would love
to exercise but it's denied to them
and given to human beings so i thank god
for it
and i will do my best under the
direction the guidance of his spirit
to present his word plainly boldly
directly without any fear but with
compassion
because i too am a sinner
i observe that and i speak
very bluntly sometimes but blunt
speaking saves time you seem to be quite
noisy
and i don't do well when a worship
environment is noisy
and i suspect god doesn't do well either
so i will appeal to you as children of
god
to be reverent you want to say something
say amen
but other than that let me do the
speaking
when i see you talking it bothers me it
disturbs me and
god knows i speak the truth and i wanted
to let you know that without any
mingling of words
that i like to preach in a referent
atmosphere
the spirit of god is the most sensitive
member of the godhead
the bible says any word spoken against
the son
will be forgiven but if you speak
against the holy ghost
it shall not be forgiven in this world
neither in the world so the holy ghost
is very sensitive he leaves quickly
and does not come back quickly so we
don't want to drive him away
by a lack of reverence
i don't know if it's in the culture to
be noisy but if it is
please don't practice that culture uh
when i'm in the desk and went past the
bar either he'll probably tell you the
same thing
it is now what is it
a quarter of five all right i'll be done
before
5 30. i promise you that uh
my policy when i preach when i've said
what i have to say stop
those of you in theology schools
remember that when you've said what you
have to say
stop don't just speak the occupy time
speak to make a point when you've made
it anything else will just ruin it so i
when i'm done i'm done and you can go on
the trails i heard someone talk about
earlier how many of you are not
seventh-day adventists can i see your
hands
you are not a seventh-day adventist may
is your hand
no one all those of you who are 70
advertisements may i see your hands
all right hands down before i go any
further
do three things for me favors i call
them favor number one
i'd like you to turn off all cell phones
anything that makes a noise please turn
them off not down
off let me explain why i want them off
and it's a request from a guest if you
turn it down and it vibrates or
does whatever it does curiosity will
lead you to check to see who's calling
and when you look furtively to see who's
calling the person next to you will look
to see what you're looking at
and that will cause disturbance so
please you won't
turn your phones on in the courtroom
don't turn them on in the presence of
god so i suspect i believe i hope i
trust
that all phones have been turned off
favor number two while i'm speaking i'd
like you to pray for me
what i'd like you to say is lord put
your words
in that man's mouth that is based on
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9
then the lord put forth his hand and
touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words
in thy mouth my words have no power they
cannot save and they
perhaps will hurt but the words of god
will save
they will rebuke they will cut but they
will heal
and restore enlighten and save and so i
want to speak
god's words not mine and fear number
three
i want you to think and this request is
based on isaiah 1 18 where the bible
says come now
and let us do what reason together to
reason means to employ the faculty
that lifts us above the level of the
animals
we can think and reason and by the
thinking the reasoning the choices we
make
we develop the character god desires us
to work out through the power
of his spirit let's pray now loving
father in heaven
in the name of jesus christ a name you
always accept
we come before you we ask you firstly
god forgive us where we have offended
you where we have sinned
forgive us there father yes we sin very
often
but your word says you're long suffering
and so pardon us one more time with the
forgiveness give us power
that we may not repeat whatever it was
we did
father we've gathered to listen to your
word and as i try to deliver this
message i ask you that god please help
me
put your words in my mouth remember the
promise you made to moses in exodus
chapter 4 verse 12
when you said to him now therefore go
and i will be with thy mouth and teach
thee what thou shall say
teach me god and give me the spirit to
listen and to speak only as
your spirit leads and convicts bless
every person under the sound of my voice
bless the
english language institute father school
the foreign language school
and the mission for which it was
established when this weekend is over
let us all leave this place drawn closer
to your bosom
more committed to the cause of the
gospel i offer this prayer from my heart
in jesus name amen
our subject for this afternoon promise
and
power promise and
power
i was reading your mission statement on
the internet
and at the end of that page
the statement says or there's a
statement
the command and commission of christ is
given to us
and then matthew 28 18-20
is quoting
and jesus came and spake unto them
saying all power is given unto me in
heaven
and in earth go you therefore teach all
nations
baptizing them in the name of the father
and of the son
and of the holy ghost teaching them to
observe
all things whatsoever i have commanded
you
and know i am with you always even unto
the end
of the world that's a command
and i'll say something about a command
every command
from god how we ought to view it but
i'll leave that verse right there
and i want you to listen to hebrews
chapter 4 verse 2 or you can turn to it
in your bibles
hebrews chapter 4 we read verse 2.
have you found hebrews
chapter 4 verse 2.
the bible says for unto us was the
gospel preached as well as unto them
but the word preached did not profit
them
not been mixed with faith in them that
heard it
listen again to what the bible says
for unto us those are the days of the
apostle paul
was the gospel preached as well as unto
them
who is them the israelites wandering in
the wilderness for 40 years
unto us the same gospel preached in the
days of paul
was preached to the israelites because
there's only one gospel
but the word preached did not profit
them
not being mixed with faith in them that
heard it
how is that possible particularly when
you
understand what the gospel is let's go
to romans chapter 1 we shall read verse
our subject is promise and power romans
chapter 1
reading verse 18
the bible says for i am not ashamed of
the gospel of christ
why for it is what the power of god
unto salvation to everyone that
believeth to the jew first
and also to the greek the bible says the
gospel
is the power of god
that same power that said let there be
light and there was light
that same power that said lazarus come
forth that same power
that brought christ from the second
death
is the power of the gospel
ephesians 1 verse 19 says and what is
the exceeding greatness of his power to
us
who believe according to the working of
his mighty power
which he wrought in christ when he
raised him from the dead
the power that brought christ from the
second death
is a very power in the gospel that works
in the life
of the person who receives it yet the
bible says the word preached
did not profit them
how could all the power of god
not profit someone not
being mixed with faith
in them that heard it
there are two ways to hear
[Music]
with your ear or with your heart
you can hear and not heed
are you with me when the word of god is
preached and spoken and read
we ought to heed
and so unto us was the gospel preached
as well as unto them
but the word preached did not profit
them
i want to talk about the school for
which you work
the samuel foreign language school is
that one of its names
you've gathered this weekend because
you're facing challenges if i'm right
am i right yes or no you're facing
challenges with the school
and you've gathered presumably to
recommit yourselves to god
to look more closely at the mission of
the school the reason why you came
the potency of your commitment to the
work of god
did you come because the pay is
respectable did you come because
vacations are paid
and there's the opportunity to go
traveling all through southeast asia
did you come to get away from your
family did you come
to find a spouse
why did you come
why is the school facing challenges
how could something face a challenge
when it's backed up by the power of god
and how can there be discouragement
among people who presumably have a
relationship
with a god who can simply say let there
be light
and there was light how
hebrews 4 2 tells us the reason why all
the power of god that's what the gospel
is did not profit the israelites
the problem did not lie with the broad
preached
because to say the problem lay with the
gospel
is to say the problem is resident in god
and it is not
whenever things go wrong among us
whenever there is conflict between us
and god the problem is always with us
the bible says in psalm 145 verse 17
the lord is righteous in all his ways
and holy in all his works
so he is always right contrary
to our human tendencies to charge god
with the responsibility for the things
that go wrong god
is always right
let god be true and every man
a liar
matthew 28 18 to 20.
gives us a command go ye therefore
and teach all nations
we usually read the great gospel
commission from verse 19 as i just did
go therefore and teach all nations
but it is a catastrophic mistake
to read the gospel commission and
exclude
verse 18. let me explain why
listen to verse 18 and jesus came and
speak unto them saying
all power is given unto me
where in heaven and in earth now heaven
and earth is a biblical expression for
everywhere
because no one will argue that jesus
there is a place somewhere in the
universe where jesus has no power
no one can say that so heaven and earth
means everywhere
jesus has power even in hell
and so he said all power not some
all is given unto me
in heaven and earth then grammatically
speaking for those of you you
all teach english so you teach grammar
he says go ye therefore what is the
grammatical
function of the word therefore what is
the structural role
of therefore in verse 19
it connects verse 19
to what was said in verse 18 more than
connection
because you can connect to things that
are unrelated
as so many marriages are
but therefore connects two things that
should follow logically
one from the other are you with me and
so jesus says let me
give you the words of christ with one
word added in
and jesus came and spake unto them
saying because
all power is given unto me in heaven and
earth
go ye therefore
and so the command to go is
based upon the prior assurance that the
person
sending you has more power than the
opposition you'll face
not only does he have more power he has
all power
all satan has is really if you look at
it permission
in last defense page 243 why did you
turn the lights on
who turned them on please turn them off
things all in my eyes just turn them off
just turn them off my handsome brother
yes yes cut them cut them kill them do
whatever is necessary
ah thank you very much god bless you and
your family in last day events page 243
paragraph four ella white writes these
words the same
destructive power exercised by evil
by holy angels when god commands
will be exercised by evil angels when
god permits
which gives us insight into how evil
angels exercise power
it is purely by permission
there is nothing satan can do that god
does not allow
are you with me and so let's go back now
to jesus christ
all powers given to me jesus has
power does not need permission satan
needs permission
so that you have christ on your side
as you make your tentative steps
to carry out his command
go he therefore teach all nations
baptizing them in the name of the father
and of the son
and of the holy ghost let me underscore
the power that jesus christ has
in colossians chapter 2 verse 9
the bible says for in him which is
christ
excuse me dwelleth all the power of the
godhead
bodily
since you didn't get it let me rephrase
it
how much power does god the father have
all how much power does god the holy
ghost have
all how much power does god the son have
you take three alls
you combine them and put them where
in jesus
do you see why it is such an insult to
doubt god
to doubt his power to panic when you
come to the red sea
forgetting is god who created the sea
and the seas obey him
so when he said peace be still the
disciples were amazed and they feared
exceedingly mark 4
41 saying what manner of man is this
that even the wind
and the sea obey him
because he has all power
in him dwelleth the power of the godhead
bodily and so we have the power of god
on the right side
and the challenges you're facing on the
left
here's what human beings do it's a
natural tendency of the flesh
to focus on the problem not on the power
and so when three armies came against
jehoshaphat in second chronicles chapter
jehoshaphat began to pray from verse
five or six and he got to the end of the
prayer in verse 12 he said oh our
god will thou not judge them for we have
no might
against this great company that cometh
against us neither know we what to do
this is the company coming against us we
have no power
three armies against one one army
against one is bad enough
three against one is guaranteed defeat
but he ends the prayer in verse 12 by
saying
our eyes
jesus christ has all power
to deal with all difficulties hebrews
tells us in hebrews chapter 11 verse 25
by faith they pass through the red sea
as by drying the head
which the egyptians are saying to do
were drowned
in early writings page 227 paragraph one
we have these
these unsettling words loi says
i saw now whatever
difficulty you may have with ellen y
when you read where she says i saw
show a little respect for the
authenticity of what's following
now if you read where she says i feel
maybe when you read
i saw or i was shown
or i was instructed lay down your human
arrogance and
accept the divine inspiration i saw
that if the church had always retained a
peculiar
holy character the power of the holy
spirit
which was imparted to the disciples
would still be with her
the sick would be healed devils would be
rebuked and cast
out and she would be mighty and a
terror to her enemies
we read the book of acts and we marvel
at the power of the early church
and what our last day prophet is telling
us if
we had kept the character of that old
early church the power they had
we would have
there is no reason for god's word
to falter and stumble and fail
other than our lack of faith and our
unwillingness
to follow god with exactness
there's a text with which we're all
familiar but the prophecy came not in
all
time by the will of man but holy men of
god spake
as they were moved by the holy ghost
now the bible is a holy book
and it was written by whom holy men
this is a concept very difficult for us
to grasp in the 21st century
because in our modern world your
character
has very little to do with your work
and so you can be an adulterer an
adulteress a
homosexual a lesbian and as long as you
have a certain talent
you're glamorized glorified and people
pay lots of dollars to see or either
play a game
or have commit fornication on the screen
or do something else
nothing to do with your account as a
matter of fact the worse your character
is
the more you're glorified
i'm saying that to come to this point it
is not enough
to do god's work or to attempt to do
god's work
the person doing the work must have a
character
consistent with the character of the
work can you say amen
we need holy people to do a holy work
and so as we gather this week
to look at the challenges the school is
facing we ought to begin not by looking
at the school
looking at us am i committed
is the work of god my priority number
one
what is our theme song nothing between
my soul and my savior
and the savior's work is as dear to the
savior
as anything can be because it's a work
of salvation
that's why he came to die and the value
of a soul is
measured by that cross and so the work
of god is dear to him
as his very heart
promise and power
jesus assured the disciples
let me tell you who is sending you
before you take one stand
i have all power in heaven
and in earth this wasn't the first time
that christ
spoke words to that effect in exodus
chapter 20 verse 1 the bible says
and god spake all these words saying i
am the law of thy god
which have brought me out of the land of
egypt and out of the house of bondage
now it takes very little study to
realize the voice from sinai
was the voice of christ the same man who
died on that cross
was the one who said thou shalt have
know the gods before me
it was jesus christ who stood on sinai
and spoke the ten commandments of his
father
but he did not begin by saying thou
shalt have no other gods before me
neither did he begin by saying go if
therefore teach all nations
as he began all is given to me
he says virtually the same thing by
reminding the israelites
of who it was that was about to tell
them how to live their lives
i am the law thy god which have brought
thee out of the land of egypt and
out of the house of bondage what christ
was saying
implicitly i am the one who demonstrated
power
such as pharaoh had never seen or you
i am the one who turned water to blood
i brought frogs upon the land i brought
lice
i brought flies i brought moraine i
brought boils
i brought locusts i brought hail i
brought a thick painful darkness
i sent the destroying angel you saw
every one of those
expressions of power i brought you out
by a stretched out arm
and a mighty hand i was the one who
parted the red sea
i turned bitter water into sweet i sent
blood from heaven
i brought water from a rock i am the law
of thy god which have brought you out of
the land of egypt
and the same power by which i delivered
you
i will enable you to have no other gods
before me
and so one can correctly say as he reads
exodus 20 verses 1 and 2
and god speak all these words saying i
am the law thy god bishop brought me out
of the land of egypt
and out of the house of bondage and if
you will trust me you will not have in
the gods before are you with that as a
promise
i told you i would talk about what a
promise really is
if you truly accept me as the powerful
god
you will not make idols it's not so much
thou shalt not it is thou
let me say differently it's not so much
don't do that don't do that
it is these things you will never do
if you accept me fully you just won't do
that
it's a promise says god you will not
live that lifestyle
christ object lesson space 38 paragraph
one
these powerful words from elohim
in every command and in every promise
of the word of god is the power
the very life of god by which the
command may be fulfilled
and the promise realized he who by faith
receives the word is receiving the very
life and character of god
you didn't get it
listen again let me speak more slowly
in every command and in every promise
in the word of god is the power
the very life of god
by which the command may be fulfilled
and the promised
realized in other words the power of god
is the life of god
he who by faith receives the word
is receiving the very life and character
of god
and so when jesus said go ye therefore i
teach all nations
baptizing them in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy ghost
teaching them to observe all things not
some not the non-controversial things
all things whatsoever i have commanded
you and law i am with you always even
unto the end of the world
in that word lay the very life of god
because the power of god's word is his
life
education page 126 paragraph 4
the creative energy that called the
world into existence
is in the word of god this word imparts
power
it begets life very similar to what we
read in christ
object lesson space 30 and paragraph one
every command
she says in education page 126 paragraph
four
is a promise that she goes on to say
accepted by the will
received into the soul it brings with it
the life of the infinite one
who is the infinite one god himself
accepted by the will to accept by the
will
is to submit and surrender to whatever
the world says
that is accepting something into the
will
because the will is the cockpit the
controls the
aerial craft of your life and mind
that's where decisions are made
that's what god wants to control
accepted by the will
received into the soul
it brings with it the life of the
infinite one
it transforms the nature and recreates
the soul
in the image of god and so what i'm
trying to get across to you is that when
jesus said
go ye therefore the power to go and to
do what jesus says
is the very life of god which he imparts
to you through
what through what
the word
promise and power
every promise of god or every command is
a promise
every promise has power but if we go
back to hebrews chapter 4 verse 2
for unto us was the gospel preached as
well as unto them
but the word priest did not profit them
all the power of the father
the holy ghost and of christ which is in
every promise of christ
did not profit them not being mixed with
faith
in them that hurt it my question to you
is this don't answer me
do you believe with all your heart that
what you're doing is the will of god
are you 100 committed to this work
whether you do it for a year or five
it is not the length of service it is
the quality of service
are you 100 committed to
leading those students to christ whether
through direct bible study
or christ-like method of teaching in the
classroom
and a christ-like demeanor outside of
the classroom
god does not accept 99 it's very
impressive at a secular level
it's very impressive in korea united
states england sweden belgium
it is not impressive in heaven
god for those of you who've studied
physiology when a muscle contracts every
muscle fiber contracts
in a way that's called all or nothing
so when you do this in the gym the
fibers in your muscle
they contract with everything they have
i'm giving this example to make a
spiritual point
that's the effort god requires of us
ecclesiastes 9 for stem whatsoever thy
hand fine is to do
do it with i might and so my question is
to you
again are you committed to this work
with all your might you know jesus was
talking to a group of pharisees
and a scribe overheard him and in mark
chapter 12 from verse 20 the bible says
and one of the scribes came
and having heard them reasoning together
and perceiving that he answered them
well asked him
which is the first commandment of all
and jesus answered him said the first of
all the commandment is here or israel
the law of thy god is one lord and thou
shalt love the lord thy god with all thy
heart
and with all thy soul and with all thy
mind and with all thy strength now with
everything you have jesus says that's
how we love god but to love god
is to serve god to love god is to obey
god and so christ says
our commitment to god our service to god
our obedience to god must be with
everything we have
because god's commitment to our
salvation was with everything he had
withholding nothing
when god gave christ he gave everything
and had nothing left
whatever challenges you're facing
the answer lies with god the problem
lies with us
the answer lies with god the path to the
answer
is a re-commitment of the life
to god let me ask you
some questions don't answer me it's 14
after 5.
when did i say i'd let you go 5 30 i'll
try to keep my word
when you make decisions for your
personal life is god your first thought
don't answer me the last time you went
shopping for clothes
what was your first thought will these
clothes make me look good
or will these clothes when they're on me
reflect
my savior what was your first thought
when you went to the hairdresser and you
said give me that hairstyle
what was your first thought the image of
god
or making my own image when you decided
to come
from wherever you came from australia
united states uk
there are certain countries from which
you receive missionaries i saw on your
website
did you come for the cause of the
kingdom believing that by your
concentrated humble efforts
you may hasten the coming of christ by
one minute
or did you want an adventure
in southeast asia
my friends the things which are
impossible with men
are possible with god
every crisis the israelites faced was a
crisis for them
it was an emergency for them not really
for god
the red sea was a problem for the
israelites not god
thirst was a problem for the israelites
not god
the lack of food a problem for the
israelites not god but
when they trusted god
when they did what god said without
offering god creative recommendations
god moved in a miraculous way every day
seven days away forty years
you know god likes to god works by
miracles
if god is god with all that power god
can't work
in ways that are non-spectacular
they may look non-spectacular to us but
god's ways are always spectacular
when you send bread from heaven six days
a week and none comes on the seventh day
that is spectacular the very fact it
does not come on the seventh day
is as spectacular as the fact it comes
on the fifth day
let god work a spectacular work in your
individual lives
this weekend
if he can accomplish that whatever
challenges you face
will begin to vanish
for years i've heard of your school this
is my first visit south korea
i've always wanted to come and see have
some exposure
to this english language institute
this school where people teach english
and where i see pictures on the internet
because many south koreans come to our
missionary training program
in michigan and so they talk about where
they come from
and i've always wanted to have some
exposure some experience
to this samuel foreign language school
and by god's words here i am
i was surprised by the fact that you're
having challenges
but i've lived long enough and traveled
extensively enough and
counseled intensively enough to know
that there's no problem that god cannot
solve
but the solution begins with us
it begins with a recommitment of the
life to god
and to his mission and to truly ask
ourselves
is god's work my number one priority
i was listening to a message about a
year and a half ago it was given at gyc
a fellow called rosario don't remember
his first name i think it was
well i forgot there are a few brothers
called rosario and in his message he
said something very true
he said if the first century christians
were to awaken from the grave
and observe us and our level of
commitment
they would be shocked and begged to
return to the grave
now if we could be transported
by some beaming machine
back 2000 years to observe them
we would all brand them as fanatics
something has happened in 2000 years
we need to go back to the way it was
and otherwise says before christ comes
there will be a return to what
primitive godliness
we will go back to the time when god's
work is so clearly number one
it becomes apparent to all those who
come into contact with us in hebrews
chapter 11 verse 14 speaking of abraham
isaac jacob and all the patriarchs and
the matriarchs the bible says
for them that say such things declare
plainly
that they seek a country listen to the
words for they that say such things
what they said verse 13 there are
strangers and pilgrims on the earth
they that say such things declare
plainly
that they seek a country now the word i
like there is
plainly by their lifestyles
the unbelievers could see these people
were headed somewhere else
plainly how plain is it
to your friends and your family
how plain is it to your students that
your one mission in life
is the kingdom of god and his
righteousness
if someone has to guess for too long
there's a problem with my commitment
all power says christ is given unto me
and whatever excuse you may have god has
the answer
in exodus chapter 4 verse 10 reading
onwards when god called moses the bible
says and moses said unto the lord o my
lord
i am not eloquent neither here to sins
thou has spoken unto thy servant but i
am slow
speech and of a slow time god told him
go speak to pharaoh
moses said i can't speak
i'm slow of speech let's slow down the
lord said who have made man's mouth
you can't speak i made the mouth you're
not eloquent i made the tongue
who hath made man's mouth who
established the first school on earth
tell me god where was it held
the classroom was eden who were the
students
what was the lesson book nature
now the god who established the first
school he can say to us as he said to
moses
moses said i cannot talk god said who
made the mouth
we may say our school has problems god
says who established schools
i did schools are a divine invention
i should say schools of the prophets so
whatever the difficulty is
we just need to obey god as moses needed
to obey
and not drive god to the place where the
bible says the anger of the lord was
kindled against moses
in verse 14 of exodus chapter four
twenty after five
i want you to do something today right
now
it's not a command it's a request but
it's an earnest request
search your heart searching
is god's work your number one priority
i'm not suggesting everyone should be a
preacher a calporter
a bible worker my question is is
god's work your number one priority
whether you're a lawyer a doctor a pilot
a housekeeper whatever it is if you are
a member of god's
remnant family his kingdom
must be priority number one
and so jesus says in matthew 6 33 but
seek ye
first the kingdom of god and his
righteousness
it is possible to run an institution
with
organizational flawlessness and god has
nothing to do with it
so you went to hartford you studied
organizational management and you bring
back those secular skills and you run a
school and in the eyes of the world it
is well run
but god is not in it because
jesus said seek the kingdom of god and
his righteousness
and so my question is almost at a point
of irritation
is your commitment to god 100
if it isn't make that commitment before
you leave today
this place of worship
not simply for the sake of the samyak
foreign language school
for the sake of your own salvation
for the sake of the effect of your life
on the gospel of god in general
for the sake of those who will come into
your sphere of influence
and be either blessed or cursed
we're told in historical sketches page
143 paragraph 5
we are all woven together in the great
web of humanity
and god holds us responsible for the
influence we exert over others and a
half big christian
exerts a destructive influence and so
when i say
give god 100 not for the sake of the
school alone
but for the sake of your own life your
walk with christ your influence on
others
and yes for the sake of the school
because many who walk the streets of
gold will mark the point of their
contact with christ
from the day they set foot on that
campus
and so i as i stand before you as your
brother christ
as a sinner in need of grace recommit my
life to god
right now in the presence of heaven and
earth
and i recommit my life to him for one
purpose only broken out into several
little
i always tell god for the proclamation
of the gospel
the three angels messages present truth
i commit my life right now to god to
give him all the glory the praise and
the honor i want none
i commit my life to god to making sure
that he is
always presented as a god of love and
justice
and i commit my life to god to do what
christ came to do one of the things he
came to do
to magnify the law and make it honorable
i publicly recommit my life to god
putting nothing above god and his work
not family
not friends not position not career
nothing i want to seek the kingdom
first seeking the kingdom first does not
eliminate the other things of life jesus
said seek them
first implicit in first is second third
and fourth
are you with me those things which we
currently make first jesus says no
make them second third fourth and fifth
make
me and my business first
that's the commitment i want you to make
so we go through this weekend
different people as we pray and we
strategize
and we think and we plead with god
intervene
we do so as people who have recommitted
themselves to god
how many of you will say father today
i recommit my life to you and to your
work and to your kingdom
as far as i know 100 can i see your
right hand
that i'm very serious
just your right hand if
you've raised your hand if stand with me
second call it's a little tougher
perhaps you've been serving the school
missionary teacher school has about 30
000 students 44 branches 200 committed
missionaries as your website says but it
is very possible
that in all this frenzy of service you
may have drifted from god
in your own personal life you may have
drifted from god
in all this service you do one of the
greatest barriers to personal growth is
church work
are you with me the levite was so busy
going to church he couldn't stop the
help
the man on the side of the road in whom
god was represented
so my second call is if you
are beginning to realize you have
drifted from god
in the midst of service and you want to
say father i need to come back
before my drift takes me so far that i
am too discouraged to make the effort to
come back
if you think you have drifted
spiritually from god
and you want to say father i admit i
have drifted
please i want to come back hold me
tightly
that i never drift again if that applies
to you
can i see your hand if it applies to you
drifting
dazzled by the asian culture all the
travels you've done
you've drifted keep your hands up loving
father in heaven
i come to you in the name of jesus
recommitting my life to you seeking your
mercy and your grace
and your sustaining power
where i myself may have drifted i ask
you lord to bring me back
i offer no opposition no resistance
their god in heaven register the hands
that have been raised in response to the
invitation
i have drifted no time to study god's
word
no time to read the writings of ellen
white no time to sit and
meditate upon the word no time to search
one's life with the worse
with the verse search me oh god and know
my heart try me and know my thoughts
father
register those hands those decisions and
father by the gods of love
bring them back to your bosom please
and for all of us who have recommitted
our lives to you today god 100
on the very edges of the sabbath accept
our commitment
but help us god to realize some wisdom
you've given us to ellen white
in christ triumphant page 122 paragraph
three where she writes
to follow jesus requires wholehearted
conversion at the start
and a repetition of this conversion
every day
so father let us come renew this
commitment tomorrow
and the day after and the day after as
it pleases you to prolong our lives
please god bless us
because we are the school we are the
church
we are the conference we are the union
is not brick and mortar
we are the institution so purifiers they
got
the problem with the temple of jerusalem
was not the temple it was the pharisees
and the scribes and the jews
and so jesus left it let him not say to
us
your house is left unto you desolate
please god
help us to remember that the god who
brought the israelites out of egypt
destroyed them in the wilderness for
lack of faith
and so father as we have recommitted our
lives to you today
grant us your spirit anew and afresh
forget how we've been in the past that
god cast our weaknesses into the sea
and empower us brand new
to take this new step to do your work
with a fervor
a eagerness that
matches and exceeds the work that satan
does to overthrow your work
let us not allow him to outwork us
bless the leaders of the school the
administrators
bless the students who come to learn
english father as they are taught
let their lives be touched and their
hearts transformed
bless each person their families you
know the desires of their hearts granted
to them their father
protect us all from harm and danger and
let us as we conduct ourselves this
weekend do so in such a way
that those who observed may be touched
by our witness
and as the sabbath draws on help us lord
to move into that mindset
so that we can truly observe the fourth
commandment to keep it holy
bless us i pray bless what's coming
later on this evening i ask
in jesus name let all god's people say
amen
amen god bless you you may be seated
it's 5 30 thank god for helping me to
keep my word
remember if god gives you life tomorrow
morning renew the commitment you just
made
god has recorded it he's taken it
seriously
god bless you remember this is a house
of worship
try to remember that if you really have
to engage in some conversation
perhaps you can sleep up but this
because of why we've come
this is a place where we ought to remove
our shoes from off our feet
for the place where on we sit and stand
is holy ground i can only say it
i leave it up to you god bless you